القيامة. بالقرود مزودة باسلحة
نووية وبقدرات حربية هائلة.
كبيرا امام المحللين العسكريين
بالعالم. حيث تجمع دورين
لدى الولايات المتحدة نظرا
لقوتها وبسبب نقص المعلومات حول
باحثون ان بيلجورود لن تكون جزءا
من البحرية الروسية بحد ذاتها ما
يلاحظها احد تنام في مكان بحيث
لا يستطيع احد كشفها. وتنتظر
وتلك موكل اليها تنفيذ عمليات
البحث والانقاذ بالاضافة الى
انشطة عسكرية. كما تتميز الغواصة
بقدرة كبيرة على تحمل اقصى ظروف
الابحار وتمكنها مفاعلاتها
النووية من الابحار لمدة طويلة
عاما. سرعتها تبلغ نحو سبعين
عقدة. القوة التدميرية لبيل جود
ستحمل الغواصة طائرات مسيرة او
مركبات مائية مسيرة تصل سرعتها
الغواصة المبتكرة بينما وصفت
وسائل الاعلام الغربية
الولايات المتحدة. فهل يصل الدب
الروسي لهذه الغاية? ام تقوم
باسلحته المرعبة والمختلفة
لتخفيف تصعيد الغرب عليه ولردع
التوربيدات الخاصة بالغواصة
الروسية بانها اسلحة يوم
البحار تصل الى اسطول الشمال
الروسي في فماذا نعرف عن السلاح
التوربيد الحربي الواحد منها حمل
رؤوس حربية بقوة تفجير تقدر
وزودت الغواصة بمراوح خاصة مانعة
للضوضاء صممت على نحو فريد بحيث
وتنفيذ ضربة نووية هائلة تحت اسم
مهمة خاصة او مهمة سرية. رد قوي
على واشنطن. مع تطوير الولايات
المتحدة لنظام دفاع صاروخي مضاد
عسكرية جديدة تسمى التصعيد
للتخفيف من التصعيد. فبوتين يصعد
صحيفة واشنطن تايمز اعتبرت
التهديدات تأتي في اطار عقيدة
معسكر بحري متنقل. عام الفين
وواحد وعشرين تداولت وسائل اعلام
روسية اخبارا تفيد بان الغواصة
الروسية النووية بالقرود الملقبة
متناقضين الاول بمثابة غواصة
نظيفة اي ام تحمل غواصات والثاني
يوما ما؟ وبحسب التقارير ان
الغواصة تشكل الى اليوم لغزا
تتحرك بطريقة لا يستطيع اي رادار
كشفها حتى يتفاجأ العالم بحدوث
انفجار نووي. فهل باعتقادكم
سيفاجئ بوتن العالم بانفجار نووي
عمليا. غواصة ذاتية القيادة
عابرة للقارات تعمل بالطاقة
تحتوي على مسيرة مصممة لمهمات
سرية مثل قطع كابلات الهاتف
عملها. كما انها لتنفيذ انفجارات
نووية بطريقة سرية اي انها قد
يعني ان عملياتها السرية
والهجومية ستكون قابلة للانكار
الاوامر في اللحظة المناسبة يأتي
الامر بالانفجار النووي. ويقول
بمليوني طن من تي ان تي الطربيد
الواحد يعد اقوى من هيروشيما
الى مائتي ميل في الساعة ما يجعل
اعتراضها صعبا جدا. الغواصة
بالقرود مزودة بستة طوربيدات
نووية من طراز بوسدون الواحد
قادرة ايضا على الغوص الى عمق
الف متر في اعماق البحار
اقرب الى كونها معسكرا او ثكنة
عسكرية متنقلة. قدرات الخارقة.
تتميز بهيكلها الذي يمتد من تسعة
وعشرين مترا الى مئة واربعة
استعدادات لحرب عالمية والبقاء
دائما يا اصدقائي. فهل تترك
الامريكية وكذلك الصين ومعظم
الدول حول العالم. نحن امام
العميق. تثير الغواصة الروسية
النووية بالقرود مخاوف متعددة
للصواريخ الباليستية بدأت روسيا
في تطوير قدرة استجابة للغطس
جدا لطربيدات بوسدون. عند
اقترابها من شاطئ العدو دون ان
النووية والرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين هو من يشرف شخصيا على
والانترنت الموجودة تحت سطح
البحر تقول التقارير هدف مثير
وثمانين مترا وهي قادرة على حمل
ست طائرات بدون طيار وهي بذلك
بعض المصادر اكدت ان الغواصة
تتمتع بقدرة فريدة على التسلل
بغواصة نهاية العالم او وحش
المحيطات ذات الاغراض الخاصة
بدون الحاجة الى التزود بالوقود.
مهمات سرية غواصة نهاية العالم
صغيرة بطول خمسة وخمسين مترا
يمكن ان تحمل خمسة وعشرين شخصا
للعدو او السفن دون الاصطدام
بها. وتحمل بالقرود اسفلها غواصة
والمحيطات. ما يعني انها قادرة
على المرور اسفل حاملات الطائرات
يمكن ان يولد تسونامي يصل
ارتفاعه الى تسعين مترا كما
الناتو لتطوير ترسانته ومعداته
واسلحته العسكرية خوفا من التأخر
الروسي الجديد. تعد بلجرود اكبر
غواصة نووية مريت منذ ثلاثين
وفيما يستمر الغرب بتسليح
اوكرانيا باحدث الاسلحة اسعى
نظرا الى محركاتها من جهة
وهيكلها العازل من جهة اخرى.
التي لا تملكها اي قطعة بحرية
على الاطلاق. حيث يستطيع
امام الترسانة الروسية وهو ما
تفعله الولايات المتحدة
باكثر من مائة وثلاثين مرة. يا
لهذه القوة الخارقة. مفترسة
اوكرانيا دون حسم بعد مرور نحو
خمسة اشهر على عملية الغزو.
منها بحجم حافلة مدرسية ويطلق
عليها طوربيدات الهلاك الفريدة
العالم بالقرود ذات الاغراض
الخاصة وهي من نوع. الغواصة
طول انتظار. البحرية الروسية
تستلم فعليا اطول غواصة في
ما وصفت انها اكبر غواصة في
العالم. وبينما تستمر المعارك في
روسيا تكشف عن الغواصة الاكبر.
احدث سلاح مدمر للترسانة
هذا الذي يجري؟ ولماذا كل هذه
الاسلحة الضخمة والفتاكة التي
تمت تغطيتها حفاظا على سريتها
اثناء حفل اطلاقها. اما اليوم
الشديدة بشأن خصائص الغواصة
ومهماتها الفريدة وقدراتها فان
اعماق البحر لاجراء تجارب جديدة
للمرة الاولى. وبالرغم من السرية
للبحار فهي قادرة على محو الدول
على اليابسة فهي معسكر بحري
يحضرها بوتين؟ وما هو هذا السلاح
الروسي الذي تخشاه الولايات
الغواصة الاطول في العالم يا
الهي. ما هذه القوة العظمى
شبح المحيطات ومفترسة البحار
غواصة نهاية العالم. اذا طافت
العسكرية الروسية عن اي سلاح
يمتلكه الروس نتحدث يا سادة ما
الفيديو. اربطوا الاحزمة. سباق
التسلح. بعد الدعاية المكثفة
لصاروخ الشيطان الاكبر الذي
سبقته دعاية كبيرة للطائرة
والسرية والتي تعد الاطول
والاضخم في العالم انطلقت الى
الدول وجودها وسيادتها وامنها
للحظ? لا لم يعد ذلك خيارا.
الاقوى والاعظم في العالم طائرة
يوم القيامة اعلنت روسيا تشغيل
المتحدة لمعرفة ذلك واكثر؟ دعونا
ننطلق في رحلتنا خلال دقائق هذا
والخارقة وبعد صاروخ الشيطان
الاكبر وطائرة يوم القيامة?
متنقل قادرة على محو مدن باكملها
من مكانها دون ان تتحرك هي
الحرب وتشتعل سماء العالم وبره
وبحره بنيران اسلحة بوتين.